our studio which is integrated
development environment for our language
and it is used to improve the workflow
of data analysis in our when we open it
we will encounter four different
sections in our interface we have the
environment section the file section the
console section and the scripting
section which is marked as United one
here aside from them we have many other
buttons and toolbars like plots packages
markers terminals and many others and
we'll speak about them later for now
let's use the environment section to
import our first dates we go to import
data set select from text and select the
file and the directory we want to use in
this case I'm using the expression table
from the cell line project and after I
click open I will see some previews of
my date
I can see for example that we have a tab
delimited file which is a common thing
when dealing with txt files but below
that we have a data frame preview and I
can see that my labels are not okay I
have some beasts showing up here which
are not part of my data so I want to fix
this issue with the labels I'm gonna go
to heading click yes and under the row
names I will click use first column now
my labels are fine I have differentiated
labels from numbers and my dataset is
ready to be imported I click import and
my data will show up on the top left
under the global environment I can see
that I have created a data frame that
consists of labels and numbers it can
consist of many other things in this
case we have 1,000 observations and 11
variables 1,000 observations are 1,000
genes you can review them and what 11
variables are 11 samples you can also
scroll left-right and reviewed so we
have created data frame it's created
here next to the coding section so this
top left section is used for the coding
it's used to view the data and can be
used for many other things and we'll
speak about that later now let's review
the file section it is used to access
the files go through directories set
working directories and many other
things we can go to this button with
three periods for example it says go to
directory if we click that we can see
that directory is set to documents by
default but we can change that we can go
for example to desktop and we can access
the cell line project folder created and
click open I have now access this
directory it contains other files from
cell line project and I can set this as
my working directory by clicking more
and we'll speak about that later
now we have reviewed the file section
let's go to the console section console
section is used to execute code but it
can be also used to write code whatever
we do in our it will write the code in
the console section and execute it when
we imported data set it have written
this code here and executed we can write
the code in the scripting section and in
the console section but these are two
very different types of coding sections
for example if I write something in the
scripting section I can edit it I can
run Diagnostics on it I can use many
tools I can include annotations and then
I can ride around the call code or the
parts of the code that I want on the
other hand console is very direct
whatever I write there after clicking
enter it will just run and execute the
code I have written so right now we have
reviewed the console section and let's
go to the scripting section I want to
create a first line of code in the
scripting section
which will create a summary of the data
for these 11 samples and 1000 genes I
will go to the United 1 which is the
scripting file and I will type summary
after typing summary two semi columns
will appear and I want to include the
name of the data frame I imported in
this between these two semi columns we
type expression and these two options
will appear will select the exact name
of the data frame we created after
selecting it we can see that it matches
the name of the data frame so now we
have created the first line of the code
and we can run it using this button on
the right which says run after running
this line of the code it will be run in
the console section below which is also
where it will be executed and will have
outputs and results from the code